all right, it is not been a good few weeks
for Donald Trump.
And yesterday he had an absolute tantrum when
meeting with speaker of the house, Nancy Pelosi,
as well as other leaders.
And it has devolved to such a point that concerns
about Donald Trump's mental health, which
I've been raising for more than a year, our
becoming front and center because the behavior
is so on the fringes.
Trump yesterday met with house leadership
because Congress passed a bipartisan rebuke
of Donald Trump's decision to pull troops
from Northern Syria.
So Trump brings speaker of the house, Nancy
Pelosi to the white house.
Some of his generals are their other advisors.
And after the meeting it starts to become
clear that something really odd went down.
Chuck Schumer saying that Trump turned the
meeting into a diatribe that included just
attacking Nancy Pelosi personally.
That many in the room say was completely insulting.
So it was clear, something weird happened.
And then this picture was released from the
meeting in which Donald Trump's side of the
table looks visibly pained as Nancy Pelosi
is standing and pointing and appearing to
lecture Donald Trump the way you might lecture
an eight year old that just isn't behaving.
And Trump has this indignant look on his face.
But as usual, Trump put the picture out to
make Nancy Polosi seem unhinged.
This is the, the pattern Trump puts out the
truncated version of the Ukraine phone call
thinking it vindicates him and it's incriminating.
Trump puts out the letter he wrote to president
Erdogan thinking it makes them look strong
and it makes him look like an absolute lunatic.
And here Donald Trump puts out this picture
thinking it makes him look good.
But when you look at the org Pelosi unhinged,
but when you look at the picture, if you look
at the other people in the room, it is abundantly
clear that Trump is the one behaving oddly
here.
Once again, like the petulant child.
And if you look at a closer shot of the advisors
that are sitting to Donald Trump's right,
they have that pained, unfortunate grimace
on their faces looking down at the table in
embarrassment as Nancy Pelosi scolds Trump
as if he's a little kid.
And of course he often acts like one.
So then hours go by.
It becomes clear that Donald Trump appears
to have cracked during this meeting.
And Nancy Pelosi actually says, now I'm concerned
Trump's health.
The implication of course being mental health,
because this was a serious meltdown,
I'm really sad about it, is I pray for the
president all the time and I tell him that
I pray for safety and that of his family.
I think now we have to pray for his health
that ESIS was a very serious meltdown on the
president.
The behavior is erratic, childish, and it's
dangerous all at once simultaneously.
And then of course, after the meeting, Donald
Trump making no sense, totally dissociating
from the reality of the situation, talking
about how they're dealing with a region that
has lots of sand.
Syria may have some help with Russia and that's
fine.
It's a lot of sand.
They've got a lot of sand over there.
So there's a lot of say that they can play
with,
listen, the mental health red alert, if not
now, when, I mean, seriously, if this is not
enough for us to say, and I don't mean us,
like just the people on the left who have
been following Trump's deterioration, I mean
the American public, if this is not enough
for us to say something is wrong with this
man.
Now this doesn't excuse his lack of morality
and ethics.
This doesn't excuse his terrible misguided,
ignorant political views.
But on top of it, there is obviously something
going on either cognitively and or, uh, with
substance abuse here that he can not put together
a sensible take on anything.
He can not speak reasonably to anyone, whether
it's the Turkish president in that unhinged
letter that he wrote or to Nancy Pelosi at
the white house.
And then in the background, every single one
of these missteps and bizarre things that
Trump does is not merely entertainment and
casual concern.
This is a national security risk, and we are
seeing that immediately within hours after
his decision to pull truths from Northern
Syria.
Something has to be done.
The quickest path may still be removal by
voting him out in November of 2020 but are
we ready to have the adult conversation that
even Republicans need to concede that something
is very wrong at a fundamental level?
I don't know.
I don't know that they're ready to make that
acknowledgement.
To make sure you're following me on Instagram
at [inaudible],
ms.
Dot.
Pacman, and while you're there, follow the
show on Instagram at David Packard's show.
Quick break right back off to ditch